tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video
io sono un fan di j questo è il padre di
uk e siamo su happy with no non siamo su
smette di fare il [ __ ] passiamo ad
elvis era vuota cazzo non era what pop
wrestling destro poi fammi andare con
indiana dai che non faccio non uso mai
stupro cristiana l'ho preso dal bene
cosa gli devo fare a questo cosa li
dovevo fare perché mi hanno siculo alla
ascolta mizio fammi capire cosa dovrei
fare a ma devo solo ucciderlo non c'è
una vittoria perfetto belcantista casa
in verità è perché ti amo sting non ti
ha ucciso perché ti amo
[Musica]
lucian to2 o mio dio ragazzi salto blu
mi sembra ovvio verso l'infinito e oltre
lo scrivo come fa la mia gamba mi sarà
altamente sul culo non so se ve ne siete
accorti come faccio a fare sta roba
impossibile c'è da saltare sulle mie
bello complimenti steve beccaccia andato
dove dove due sono come cosa è successo
ho vinto va bene va bene mega jump
facciamo mega jump che mi sembra ancora
ancora con questa non mangiare a
salsiccia mentre vai avanti non si
mangia mentre si cammina hackett è stato
dato va bene ragazzi prova rifarlo un
attimo vedere se riesco a fare una roba
decente alla famiglia attivato prima e z
ciò fatta la nutella la nutella non
presa da qualcuno ma non avevo prendevo
prendere un tè la maionese poi in una
rotella ma vabbè ce la posso fare
ragazzi devo prenderla e niente sotto
c'è la salsiccia
vabbè dai mi accontento nas che mi
sembra merda non lo so che cos'è ma non
ci facciamo domande contro ho mica un
buon trophy lan da anni che bella
faccina che c'è in basso a sinistra dove
non buttarla per via laggiù ragazzi non
vincerò mai perché ci ha dei colori
troppo psichedelici sto cazzo
l'importante è vincere non si sa come
potesse usare le palle come potresti
usare degli scarti di immondizia ma
forte sehgal importante vincere denny
jazz ritorna cos'è sta roba
devo andare a è un getteranno mio dio si
sia ancora una ancora buona grazie
ancora due o tre aspetta che non ho
sentito
perfetto grazie ne avevo bisogno secondo
me io ho vinto non so e chiedo fa united
friends histoire d'eaux à u
cosa vuol dire sta roba si vabbè ma ha
messo solo i nobili quelli non pensavo
ci fossero veramente quelli di fi un tè
freddi golden freddi sarebbe nonno ciak
vuoi farmi credere che è stato lui fino
a questo momento lui lo stronzo di merda
sei stato tu eccolo prender adesso l'ho
preso bene non è mai stato così semplice
vincere la fai lette freddy's mai
andiamo al prossimo che mi sto calando
tra falling star amiamo a donna che che
poesia
so già partito volante cosa è successo a
farmi capire cosa devo fare la mia vita
cos'è sono uscite dall estero ragazzi e
ceo di livelli via più sono li sto più
capendo abbiate pazienza magic cosa
cazzo è successo nella sala che non lo
so e mi sento idiota con il bello il
livello più bello che io abbia mai
giocato in tutta la mia vita una [ __ ]
stella shipping questo non ve lo taglio
perché voglio farvi capire il disagio
rain box life una roba bella fino a to
everyone glbt in this it was made by
senpai va bene l'importante è
un'importante morire fatemi uscire a
vincere una volta sola vinco poi non
tocchino era un tocco un cazzo porca
vacca vinto e adesso ha vinto lui il mio
bolide ok ok piano piano piano che saltò
fatto
[Musica]
cazzo story mastica sta già posso fi
ragazzi ce la posso fare ciò posso fare
lo so che voi pensate che sono sfacciato
ma non lo sono io lo so io lo so la vera
spinta sentire una scura secondo me ce
la fai sei ancora culo è non lo so se ce
l'hai ancora ma nel caso prova a leo è
di rialzati devi tirarti su ce la puoi
fare io credo in terzi si non sapevo lo
sapevo cazzo non ci posso credere che ho
sempre creduto in te e te lo meriti
adesso questo pene lungo perché hai
fatto una cosa giusta imporsi ball 90
faccio questo che ormai non c'è più
niente di impossibile dopo quello che ho
fatto
forse questo siccome faccio non c'è
ragazzi non c'è abbastanza spazio per
far passare un essere umano come è
invece c'era come dai cazzo c'avevo
fatta tanta intento sorpasso come ho
fatto a vincere ma ormai guardano i
ragazzi nomi che non mi chiedono anche
qui le cose va bene così quello che
succedeva così multiplayer un altro
multiplayer facciamo questo stessa roba
bellissima cos'è che movimenti da da
corridore professionista vai maratoneta
forza ai un jet nel culo perché non lo
usi mio addio atomi hanno seminato come
se non ci fosse un domani come va più
veloce mia nonna com'è possibile a
control per il jet perfetto che cazzo
dietro che ne so io bike oggetto eco
jazz
se ho vinto io ci siamo superati di
brutto sgambetta così bravo zio bravo ti
vedo che hai preso il ritmo giusto vai
così ce l'ho fatta ragazzi non ci posso
che c'è anche un 5 ma mai così ho
battuto 5 possiamo andare ufficialmente
alle olimpiadi ormai è sicuro segway
schlamp devo andare con cosa gauck
stefano ar del cancro al pavimento
semplice c'è una mannaia nello stomaco
semplice ciao una punta nel pene
semplice ragazzi state sta diventando
tragica la cosa desta iniziare a salta
roba o muoio un'ascia un action e fegato
cazzona non lo scriva talos khatami si è
tolta anche l'altra spada schivando
tutto fenomeno ragazzi lanciatevi
addosso anche nonno cia che tanto non
temo più niente cosa mi state lanciando
cazzo grazie no era lì il traguardo di
mortacci tua madre già faccio ragazzi
stavolta non posso perdere il cazzo se
perdo ho schivato perfetto
si si si oh mio dio è stata su d'acqua
ragazzi sta diventando tragico mio dio
my face cos'è mx nova ecco ragazzi
facciamo un buffo che è una figata
pazzesca ma come occhi o scegliere belli
questi quali inizio e rendono proprio
l'idea di un puffo che bello io andrei
su questa qui che cosa cazzo mi dice che
opero di kart ma vabbè questo momento di
fisso proprio eccoci perché è bello
ragazzi ha creato la mia [ __ ]
creatura e bellissima da io la chiamerò
leonard bravo leana legami le chiappe le
social penality kick cos'è sta cosa ha
semplicemente calcio di rigore ma ci
provo ragazzi finale di champions league
manchester united contro la parrocchia
di frattamaggiore ciò possiamo fare
agazzi no ha vinto frattamaggiore sapore
da gatti lo faccio più serie 3 2 1 ed
erede e dovete frattamaggiore va giù
manchester 1 frattamaggiore 0 e finisce
la partita è stato fantastico è stata
finale dei mondiali più emozionante la
mia vita flash di ed cos'è sta roba a
devo devo tagliare le feste tanto per
cambiare come ho stoppato regala
quadrati che figo volevo togliere o
semplicemente perché non era così figo
ma ho scoperto in a ma io c'ho di fermi
immagine ed incredibili dai ragazzi
facciamo paio di miei livelli perché mi
servono ne ho bisogno fa vj nuova
canzone cosa vuol dire oh mio dio cosa
fai nonno cosa sta facendo
ade ritmo questa cosa grazie per aver
giocato se vuoi lo continuo ti ringrazio
amico mio ma preferirei di no però
grazie fa vj e le montagne vi sembra una
storia d'amore a leggere il titolo così
fa vj le montagne va bene che bella
slitta questo è il primo livello devi
cantate con le montagne sono montagne
russe ma io le rotte erano montagne
russe ragazzi con funzionano a dio sto
livello è stato bellissimo giocarlo
complimenti ragazzi concluso
quell'episodio spero che video vi sia
piaciuto è stato bello giocare anche
oggi è crisi comunque io credo che
veramente ad ogni [ __ ] episodio
diventi sempre più no senza e non è
possibile se non mettete mi piacevi
arriva un look in casa di uccida tutti
serio cook ragazzi spero che video vi
sia piaciuto casa in casa vita piaciuto
se non ti piace la capacità di sapersi
gestire 10 vi davamo proseguito ai
ragazzi